hello this is Doug Walker and next to me
is hello
he looks further away that it's the
white egg now look look at eight feet
I'm gonna squash your head hold on okay
anywho uh it's my brother obviously and
a lot of people have asked how do you
make a nostalgia critic episode for
which I I never thought it was like that
I don't know it's pretty straightforward
in my opinion but a lot of people keep
asking it's as much movie make jokes
yeah that's pretty much it but uh yeah a
lot of people have a stand the time and
stuff like that so um that's basically
what we're gonna do here uh usually what
happens that we pick a movie the one
we're doing today is a doomsday machine
for this DVD and we are going to the
first thing we do is we just watch it
and pretty much like what he said we
just make jokes we just do like Mystery
Science Theater say so we'll better at
than I am and I just write down the best
ones pretty much um so yep that's what
we're gonna do and we'll let you watch a
little bit that's closed thing to an ass
your burns SNS sounds sucking suck
thank God they only have one guard in
this entire place but you guys know you
may want to do a doctor and scene of it
yeah that's true they're breaking out
Robby the robots you should wear a wig
over her black hair it was a black wig
no if we throw a long past what I like
receiver yeah we can make the touchdown
well what do you consider unusual
circumstances anything we're not
prepared for Oh the lead when you
consider unusual circumstances things
that are unusual early it's five o'clock
at the moon according to our nearest
class I mean you guys aren't taking him
seriously are you
those chopstick jockeys quick Jack
that's a new one those Mugu pan
Oh would you care to join me on a tour
of the ship see what makes it tick you
can start my thrusters holy go or no
woman's gone the phone we have liftoff
don't dress like Powerpuff Girls
I'm the brainy one nothing up here will
wash socks so yeah that gives you an
idea how the watching experience goes
kind of get very boring near the
end there did it was about 20 meds of
just looking at the same goddamn thing
that was uh it was Manos - hands of fate
yeah that was curiously bad yeah didn't
watch it that see it the writing process
all right so you've seen us watch the
movie and we just sort of shall joke sad
and usually the way the script sort of
looks these are just sort of very basic
notes like love the soundtrack that just
reminds me to talk about the fact
there's no music closest thing to Oscar
well over see I remember that was
something in the credits
it looks like bubble and space the
credits gave up for a second and then
again I guess they came back all black
in a white wall not smart uh so all
these little things that it's not you
know even something where I'm not
entirely sure like you know should I do
an insane obit I think it's a no spelled
wrong but uh he gets her this general
idea just these jokes you know or dr.
smith joke I'm not exactly sure what I'm
gonna do with all these and I just sort
of figure it out as I'm writing now the
writing process usually takes like three
to four hours I want to say sometimes
they can take longer but usually it's
around that amount of time uh but the
reason like you know you might be seeing
some of this saying oh well he watches
the movie that takes like two hours he
writes it that takes like three to four
hours you know and then he films it that
takes about two hours why doesn't just
do this all like in one day does maybe
one long day at work there's two reasons
one is that I make other videos
sometimes Khan's pop-up or I'm working
other projects for the site so things do
pop up and it's best to pace it out but
the other reason is that a lot of times
I think it's smart with a project like
this you know to sort of once you write
down the jokes to sort just let them sit
for a bit like I'm coming back to this
the next day and if I look at a joke
like maybe in the moment I thought was
really funny but when I see it again you
know and maybe it doesn't click maybe
something just doesn't flow as much as I
thought it also gives time to think of
other ideas because once you see the
movie and then you come back to it you
can often remember what stood out the
most like what do you remember after a
day of seeing that movie because
sometimes you can see something right
after seeing in like oh yeah we'll make
a big joke out out of that but then when
you really think about it wasn't
anything that huge so uh this is all
stuff to keep in mind if you know when
and if you do something like this
now often what I'll do is I'll write the
movie or I'll write the review
for the movie while actually watching
and I highly recommend that if you ever
do this because if you ever write
something and you don't have the footage
in front of you a lot of times it's much
harder to mimic it's much harder to
remember the exact impacted ad because
sometimes you remember things
differently so in this case I'm watching
it on YouTube gets its public domain
movie and I couldn't find a DVD of it so
usually I watch it on DVD but in this
case I'm watching it on YouTube
okay so it's the next day this is
filming day and I'm gonna give you an
idea just what my scripts look like as
you can see hold on they're not
incredibly professional watching yeah uh
usually what I do is I just write them
all out like that there's no paragraph
indents or anything at all
I don't even write the line how long on
the statue because I know I'm going to
say it now you might be wondering what
the red is about what the red is to
remind me of anything that needs to be
shot that isn't just at the traditional
background like here I don't think this
is conducting coffee and that's just a
note to remind me that I have to do a
scene where I'm conducting the coffee
maker or what else here we got I see
where I'm acting as let's see the
president of Astra you know I'll
probably do that against a green screen
and here's another one where I'm gonna
do like the stand-up comedian also
whenever there's a picture that Jim
Jairaj needs to photoshop I'll you
should put that in red as well well that
gives you the general idea let's go to
the set hello as you can see it's not
very far away from my computer it's a
very very close now luckily I have two
cameras
it's channel awesome was nice enough to
get me to and a lot of people ask what
kind of camera do I use and you can see
here is the Sony HD AVC HD you can get
more information there one two point
three megapixels and I if you're looking
for that that's a camera I use the
tripod is pretty close you know to me as
you can also see it's not a huge area
you know over here it gets sort of
clunky with a lot of my computer stuff
in terms of lights that I use I only
have Tungsten's for now though I'm sorry
begin being given an education from Ed
and Lindsay about better lights to use
probably fluorescent lights would be
bear this one's been through hell as you
can see look at look at that thing there
that's been dented falling over a few
times so I gotta get a new one anyway
this one's also a tungsten is much
smaller but gets the job done this I
don't think this is a film light but
this is what was
yeah be given to be when we ask bargain
again our film lady he got is this this
one doesn't even work anymore but that
this one does it gets the job done it's
probably the brightest album so I serve
you know if you pointed more towards the
center it gets brighter so I serve
pointed more just a light of that area
sort of get a little even you know
anyone knows about light you know three
point lighting that's kind of what I
have going on here so yeah let's get to
the actual filming so as you can see I'm
just about ready to film but nuclear
winter it's totally bright here that's
because the exposure is set to high so
now what I'm gonna do on the camera is
I'm gonna bring it down a bit because
you can actually play with the exposure
on this camera I think you can play with
them actually on most cameras now before
I do that you'll see that you can
actually bring it down but alright way
too dark so you can bring it up and you
try to just sort of find that nice
medium usually about here if they even
then I serve go back and forth I think
I'm gonna do this one usually because
it's HD I try to go a bit darker so it's
a little hard to say with this I'll do
this one it could be wrong but do get do
that now here's the thing there's also a
setting for automatic exposure now you
do that that automatically gets you to
sort of the even levels but the thing
about that is now let's say I'm saying
something I want get really close you
see the lighting sort of changes when I
come back the lighting changes again I
put my hand up here the lighting chain
point back here the lighting changes
that can be very distracting and a lot
of times it can't be in your control the
camera just sort of takes it and decides
what it wants so most of the time you
want to have it on manual one you want
just get the setting right but there are
times like let's say you're filming you
know just home video or a documentary or
something like then you know you're
gonna be in a lot of places where the
Lighting's gonna be flying around a lot
and you needed to adjust quickly
sometimes it's good to have it on audio
or auto but most of the time you want it
on manual with that so let's get this
back I think that looks about right
yeah after that this looks about right
and then what I do a lot of times is
that import into the computer and
another great thing about HD is that
actually it used to be when we would
shoot that we had to go darker or
lighter we had to choose between the two
we'd go brighter so you can see it well
now with HD because it's getting so much
detail you can take it and you can turn
up the brightness and the contrast and
it won't look that bad if anything it'll
look better so if you ever if you have
an HD camera you're wondering which one
to do go darker usually just a hint
darker don't go super dark but if you
have to choose between some a little
brighter a little darker usually go a
little darker that's usually the best
route cuz you can fix it in post
everything's fixable and post ok now I
have my script here and you might be
wondering how do I know what I'm going
to say to the camera and what I'm just
gonna read honestly since it's red the
day before I can usually just sort of
remember like I remember that when I get
up to the line doomsday machine I'm
gonna go to the visuals I'm gonna play
the music I'm gonna do all that stuff so
I look over this line uh you know get it
down my head and I usually do a couple
takes hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to and
welcome to another special edition DVD
review and may I remind you because
there's no refund oh yeah you should be
moaning cuz today we got doomsday
machine all right so that's one take now
I usually don't just do one take I do
several because especially with
something where you're supposed to be
playing with your emotions and reactions
or everything in this show you have to
do a lot of various reactions so that
one got a little big you know yeah you
better be afraid this one gonna play
down a little bit hello I'm in the style
sure critic guy remember it so you don't
have to and welcome to another special
edition DVD review and may I remind you
there's no refunds oh you better mode
because today we got doomsday machine he
knows that one was a lot more chipper ah
the reason I do that is because
sometimes just the sarcasm or the
cynicism you know being positive about
something like enjoying making you
suffer can work just as well as me
getting mad at me getting angry because
if it's one tone throughout the whole
thing that it tends to be exactly that
just one tone
unknown and it can get a little boring
you want to mix it up a bit so usually
with every line I do about a minimum
three tanks sometimes I can do as many
as like ten cuz you just and you sort of
feel around you just sort of get what
you think is the best feel for it or
when you think you have a good variety
sometimes most of the time I find with
me it's either the very first take or
the very last take it's very rare that
it's one of the middle ones but
sometimes it is sometimes I get that
perfect one in the middle of value even
thinking about it and now since I know
you're not going to see me during this
clip I'm gonna just read this part while
not looking at the camera and I do it
from this angle I don't go to a
microphone because I find that the more
fluent you can make something uh when
talking usually the less distracting it
is so if my voices are kept this volume
and has this frequency throughout the
whole thing you're less likely to get
distracted from the comedy or less
likely to be sort of thrown off so with
that said I just read this part oh this
is about as pretentious sexist and
downright pointless a movie you could
ever see in the sci-fi genre now this is
going to show you the height of my
unprofessionalism whenever I have to say
something that I know I don't sort of
want this echo around I again I don't
use a microphone this is really lame I
just get really close to the camera and
the microphone is about right here so I
just sort of put my lips relatively
close to the camera so let's see here I
actually have two lines because I don't
know which one I want to do one is well
there goes two of my lies and the other
is just cat scream that just means I'm
gonna make some sort of cat noise so
here's a few of those well there goes
two of my lives well there goes two of
my lives well there goes two of my lines
now here's the one of the cat scream
well well well so that's how I do that
I'm the Nostalgia Critic a Pheo excuse
me I'm gonna find a woman to wash my
socks Oh
so there that's the main part of filming
but now as I point out before I have
these read section so I have to go film
books for example this is the scene
where I'm going to conduct the coffee
maker and literally just standing here I
got an idea because the shower might be
very much a child's play then maybe I
should incorporate the Casper joke again
so I'm going to do one shot where I'm
just conducting and then once you're out
conductor I get attacked by the ghost
that's something else I'm going to do
here is I'm going to do what they called
cheat to the camera where if I'm
conducting I'm conducting like this but
you can't see that much so I'm going to
sort of cheat my way this way which is
not how a person would normally stand
but when you're watching it on video or
on film it looks a little bit more
natural because you can see more of a
person okay now you're gonna see the
section where I film in front of the
green screen this is where I'm gonna do
the stand-up comedian now something that
you might be noticing you're two things
maybe noticing one is that hey that's
not green well the way I get around that
is that I usually crop it later but the
catch is that I can't go beyond the
green screen so whenever I use my hand
actions I have to be very you know
strapped to here um and the other thing
to keep in mind with that too is that if
I need to be shrunken down on the green
screen or something like that I don't
want to go outside the perimeters of the
screen of what I have and I do have
another green screen but if I maverick I
just do one the other thing keep in mind
when you're seeing this with your pride
thing in of is your shadows you don't
want shadows on a green screen for the
most part that's true you want keep
shadows as out of it as you can but
there's something even worse than
shadows and that's if the light is too
bright on the green screen you have a
light to really see I'll pull this one
over sir
you see how the screen starts to go a
little white when you bring the the
light a lot closer the reason that is
bad is because if you're wearing a white
shirt or you have white skin or whatever
I mean that's going to play with it as
well and that's going to sort of take
away the color in your skin when you try
to key it and for whatever reason on
Adobe Premiere anyway the key
effects have used the ultra key actually
gets rid of these shadows relatively
well it's not perfect but it actually
does sort of take them away so the
shadows in this case at least with Adobe
Premiere are not as big a problem as out
there that you know if they're like that
dark if they're that black that's bad I
mean for why you seeing now surprisingly
isn't that bad so uh yeah now I'm gonna
do my bit hey what do you call man who
just lost all logic a woman hey what do
you call a man who just lost the logic a
woman
okay so now I have the footage imported
into the computer and I use Adobe
Premiere cs5 hv technically this is a
5.5 and this is what I use to edit and
when I go through on this day is that I
go through the timeline everything that
I shot and I pick out the shots that I
like the most and sometimes if I'm not
sure maybe one shot is sort of similar
to another or maybe a lot of variations
on I'll hold on to the shaft by don't
put the video not the video that I don't
put the film footage in yet from the
movie I put in this is just going
through just getting a skeleton of what
I shot just getting everything in order
so that when I do have the film footage
I just go in there and I put it together
now I'm gonna play with the brightness
in the contrast you can see I can make
it a lot brighter I can make it a lot
darker and usually what I do the
brightness usually is not an issue it's
usually the contrast even though this
looks pretty good you can always make a
little better so I'm gonna turn the
contrast up just a touch and now the
thing with it you feel really high or
you can go really low the way it looks
great I'm gonna go to about let's see
that looks pretty good that's about 18
and yeah I have that for the rest of the
footage so usually do that at the
beginning because you don't want to have
to go in and do it for every single shot
oh yeah you should be moaning cuz today
we got the old state machine now
something I forgot to notice you'll see
is that I left about one second of
silence just looking at the camera I
don't look away I don't look down
and the reason for this I found out is
that even reviews need pacing and that
doesn't mean that you're necessarily
leaving just a long place for people to
laugh cuz you know they're gonna live
very long cuz you can't hold on a shot
for too long but I found in the
beginning a lot of times I would cut it
too fast and it wouldn't a lot of time
for what you're saying to sink in or
process or something like that and just
like a movie or I'll write or a bit of
writing or anything reviews do need
pacing so you can't just have everything
too fast you can have a fast but you
still need it to sink in for people
unless the joke is that's going so fast
you can barely process it but for a
review for like what I'm doing
uh you need to have a good pace and now
for these scenes I know I'm going to be
reading this so what I do is that I
separate the audio from the video and I
pretty much get rid of the video in
these scenes until I see a moment where
I know I'm gonna start talking again
like I can see I'm looking at the camera
now and throwing my hand up so I know
I'm gonna start talking at this point so
here I put the video right back together
so that this way as you can see now I
just have the audio I can play with and
that's gonna be much easier to edit than
having to black out the video the whole
time so it's easier just to cut the
video out and the way you know if your
sound is too loud or not is right here
and I used to ignore this but I was
wrong because i had my speakers it was
way too low so i turned the sound up way
too high and it was always distorted and
I've learned recently that I have to
just keep track of this he just tried to
keep it as little as you can in the red
so here you'll see it doesn't really go
in there as much hello I'm a nostalgia
critic guy remember it so you don't have
to know but again if you do something
really crazy like let's say is listening
to this and I said oh that's way too
softer and my speaker's turn out too low
I really want to be able to hear it
you'll get this guy remembering so you
don't have to and welcome to another
special edition now you see how much is
going in the red there and also the
reason you don't want this because the
sound gets really distorted so you
definitely don't want it to go in the
revit does once or twice for a joke
maybe but really for the most part you
want to keep away from that okay so I
just got done editing the skeleton of
the whole thing is you can see you have
a lot of areas where there's just sound
and a lot of areas where there's video
so if you said go through here oh it's a
gun read that yo bling-bling boy blank a
video play-by-play blank video so that's
sort of what I have here and then the
next thing to do which I'll start
tomorrow cuz I usually do other videos
is that I will then put in the movie and
start in certain areas where you know
that needs to go and then I'll do things
like do the green screen effect and
stuff which I will show you next
okay and this is the last day that I do
my editing and this is where I put the
movie clips in I messed with green
screen footage I put in sound effects I
do all the little technicals that you
know pretty much finalized everything
what I usually do I give myself because
you know it says five days altogether so
I give myself maybe one or two extra
days in case something goes wrong or in
case something goes longer uh which
happens a lot but usually you know I can
get done in a good amount of time but
you know you have those extra days just
in case okay now I'm going to show you a
little bit about how into the green
screen effect now remember what I was
saying before about how the shadows
actually aren't going to be that big a
problem while using the ultra key you
pick the darkest part of the shadow
which would be about here as you see
well you still got some gray in there
you know for the background color so
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna play around
with the settings of touch if you see
that looks a little better but it's a
little hard to make out because when you
don't have anything the background it
just goes totally black so I'm just
gonna take one of the pictures just for
now this is just a temporary thing until
I get a better background so here we go
that's an even gonna play around a
little bit of me and there there you go
all right so now you can see whether or
not shadows are coming through of course
you can see them over here but as for
the rest of it it's not too bad I'm
gonna maximize you see I'm getting a
little bit of graininess there and see
you see how it goes a little fuzzy there
we're gonna try and fix that up a bit
alright so I have the edges looking
pretty good about the best I'm gonna get
here uh the next thing I'm gonna do is
that I'm going to Oh what the hell is
that you got these this wall background
well that's a very easy fix all I do I
take the crop tool and I simply put that
in there and then I simply
crop it from the left and I clap it crop
it from the right so that way now looks
like there's a full background but
obviously I don't want to use this
little splash up here so I'm gonna put
in this blue background now backgrounds
you can find you know for green screen
effects or whatever there's a lot of
various places you can find them
shutterstock is pretty good deposit
photo is also pretty good I think sure
stock I like to use the most you usually
have to pay a forum but you know if use
them over and over it's pretty much
worth it
so now you have this image here when you
see me talk I was dropped in the city
but you see there's a problem there the
crop I'm starting to go a little out
there so I have to go in I had to adjust
the crop a little bit from the left side
there we go so now it's not quite as bad
next I'm going to play with the
brightness and contrast just a little
bang um it's a little brighter maybe a
little bit more colorful and I do that
because this background is just so
bright it does stand down the contrast
is so big that if you make yourself a
little colorful it'll match a little bit
more so let's see how this looks no fast
draw two minutes ago a nuclear bomb was
dropped in the city and see how I only
schedule ten seconds for this meeting
that's all I have to tell you remember
what I said especially the part about
breeding and that's how you do the green
screen effect okay so it's near the end
the day now as you can see it is night
and I am done editing this review as you
can see it sort of looks a lot more
clutter a little bit like a mess but all
the all the movie clips have now been
put in there what's that extra stuff
right there I mean this is the project
from beginning to end and now what's
this stuff these are all the other extra
shots the extra takes that I didn't use
like the ones that I just I didn't like
though hey it's a nice face there isn't
it um you know the ones I didn't like
the way they sound I thought another one
sounded better but I hold on to them
because if it turns out something in
this project didn't flow or didn't work
very well sometimes a different take is
the answer and even though at the moment
you know I like one of these other takes
if it turns out while watching it
through that maybe it doesn't flour me I
should have been more angry at one point
me I should have been more happy or
something like that the other takes are
still right there and I can preference
them very easily instead of having to
scroll through and
see where they are so basically folks
that is how you make a nostalgia critic
I next just export as an mp4 I uploaded
to the website and that's really about
it it's not too complicated but it is a
lot of work like today always takes the
longest it can be anything from a - like
12 hours pretty much just depending on
how long the review is so it's uh as I
always say though I love it so much so
it's not hard work but it's long work
and it is good work and I really do
adore it so guys thanks so much for
watching maybe you can get some good Tim
bits out of this and thanks again for
buying the DVD take care